هذه هي
تنقلاتي مع توم مارتينيز
وملايين الأمريكيين الآخرين ،
لقد كانت هذه هي الفترة الصباحية
للعمل في المنازل في جميع أنحاء أمريكا ،
العمل من المنزل هو الطريقة الجديدة للعمل ، هل
تشعر أنك قادر على أداء وظيفتك
من المنزل ،
يا جميل تمامًا  يعتمد كل
شيء أفعله على الأدوات الرقمية ، لذا فأنا
أمام جهاز كمبيوتر بنسبة تسعين في المائة
من الوقت على
أي حال ، يعمل مارتينيز لدى ناشر رئيسي
خلال عام ، وقد غيّر كثيرًا أنه ينتقل
إلى شمال نيويورك ،
ابنه لوغان البالغ من العمر 11 عامًا والذي  لقد
ازدهرت adhd في التعلم الافتراضي ،
أنا سعيد جدًا ويحب العمل
من المنزل
في البداية ، لم أكن متأكدًا مما قد
يعنيه ذلك ، لكنني أعتقد الآن
أنني رأيت أن هناك الكثير من
الفوائد لعدم الاضطرار إلى
أداء المهام  في مثل هذا النظام
المقسم والصارم للغاية ،
لكنه يقول الآن إن شركته مثل
الآخرين تكتشف كيفية
إعادة الموظفين إلى المكتب.
تخطط مدينة نيويورك لإعادة
80000 موظف في المدينة
بدءًا من الشهر المقبل ، تقول الفتاة الطيبة تايلور
سيغميلر ، وهي معالج نفسي ،
إنها يمكن أن تعود إلى المكتب في
غضون 30 يومًا ،
ما هو مستوى راحتك
وقلقك ، أود أن أقول
بالتأكيد بعض المخاوف بالتأكيد
بعض
الترقب  في العام الماضي ، رأت سي ميلر
مرضاها بشكل افتراضي
وتقول إنها تشاركت مخاوفها مع
صاحب العمل بشأن العودة إلى العمل الشخصي ،
لقد تحدثنا عن بعض
المخاوف من التواجد
في غرف صغيرة جدًا وجهاً لوجه في
بعض الأحيان لا تفعل هذه الغرف  لديها
نوافذ في كثير من الأحيان لا تكون جيدة
التهوية ، فأنت تعلم أنها
تحاول إيجاد التوازن بين ما
هو أفضل رعاية لشخص
ما وما هو الأكثر أمانًا
للجميع ، ولكن حتى مع زيادة التطعيمات ، يقول
55 في المائة من البالغين العودة إلى
ما قبل  - قد تمثل الحياة الوبائية في الوقت
الحالي خطرًا متوسطًا إلى كبير على
صحتهم ورفاهيتهم.
لكن
ما نهدف إليه
هو أن
تقول كاتارينا بيرغ ، مديرة الموارد البشرية في 100 الحرية والمرونة ، إن
الوباء
أثبت أن نموذجهم الجديد سيعمل على المدى
الطويل
، والإنتاجية والكفاءة لم
تنخفض ، أعتقد أنه مستقبل العمل ،
وأعتقد أن هذا هو ما نطمح إليه.  سنرى في
بعض الصناعات والشركات في
وقت سابق وفي بعض الصناعات الأخرى بعد ذلك بقليل ، لقد غير
هذا العام الماضي
أولويات كل من الشركات
والموظفين الذين قاموا بتغييرهم أيضًا
لمارتينيز ،
كنا جميعًا نعود إلى المنزل مرهقين ، بالكاد نجري
محادثة
ولكن  الآن نحن جميعًا نعمل معًا طوال
الوقت ونأخذ وقتًا ونستفيد منه
بشكل كبير
بدأ الناس في تقدير اللحظات
التي لدينا معًا
وهذا شيء ربما كنا نعتبره
أمرًا مفروغًا منه لمدة دقيقة هناك